Pixar has been releasing movies since
1995 but can you name all of them test
your knowledge on some of the most
popular and underrated movies ever
including the one we bet you never even
heard of now let's check out the best
fix our movies ever let's start with a
movie that's warmed all of our hearts up
pretty much made us all uncontrollably
sob it's a cute movie but it happened in
2009 which is quite a while ago so how
much do you remember from up the movie
actually became pretty famous for one of
the most wonderful sequences at the
beginning no words were needed for that
part at all it was already emotional on
its own but the entire movie is just way
too adorable Carl the old widower in
this story has to put up with a rustle
be overly ambitious and overly energetic
kid the two are just perfect for each
other
despite the early differences pop comes
with a lot of metaphors and backstories
that will make you all choked up any
last words Frederickson
come on definitely time for re-watch
Finding Nemo Finding Nemo is one of the
most quotable Pixar movies ever who
could possibly forget about just keep
swimming just keep swimming just keep
swimming swimming swimming it's all
about a tiny clown fish who gets caught
up by humans and thrown in a Sydney
dentist's fish tank he has to be rescued
by his dad Marvin and the whole journey
to the rescue is pretty extreme Marvin
also meets some colorful characters
along the way that really make this
movie a million times better seriously
this is the movie you probably end up
rewatching millions of times because
it's just so good and to remember just
keep swimming Monsters Inc Monsters Inc
is just one of those Pixar movies that
really explore the boundaries of
storytelling who would have known that
people would fall in love with these
monster characters and the adorable kid
although this movie is totally innocent
it will genuinely make you cry on more
than just one occasion we won't spoil it
for you but you'll be surprised just how
many heartfelt moments can be found in a
movie about monsters and honestly it's
absolutely amazing that the kids aren't
scared of the monsters anymore
while watching us which of course is the
whole
if it's been a while since you've seen
monsters Inc you probably have to
rewatch monsters University now here's a
Pixar movie that was really anticipated
but quickly forgotten
monsters University is of course a
sequel to monsters Inc so the
expectations of this movie were
ridiculously high it's all about Mike
and Sulley attending college and
becoming scarers that's the plot the
movie wasn't really as well received as
the first one and to be honest it was
kind of expected but it still did well
despite the fact that many forgot it
even existed monsters University does
still feature some amazing moments that
you should definitely rewatch again
finding dory remember when ellen
campaigns for finding Dory for years and
everyone collectively lost it when the
sequel was finally announced Dory was
such a big character in the first movie
everyone wants to know more about her
life but we bet you forgot about this
movie the minute after it came out the
truth is this is one of those Pixar
movies that's definitely aimed at adults
it's completely emotional and the entire
story of Doras amnesia will have you
choked up of course it doesn't hurt to
watch this one immediately after finding
Nemo - just so you can get a bit of
backstory brave as the first Disney
princess movie produced by Pixar brave
had a lot to live up to and it
definitely did set in Scotland brave
explores the Scottish heritage just as
much as it explores non-stereotypical
Disney Princesses Merida is just one of
those characters that's so unique and
she's one of the few that doesn't need a
man in fact men aren't - the main focus
of the story it's all about Merida
standing up for her own passion and
honestly that's just beautiful a bunch
of other stuff happens but we won't
spoil it for you
if you forgot all about brave you
definitely need to put it on your to
watch list Cars one who knew that a
movie about cars would be so iconic
the very first Cars movie was the one
that proved Pixar loves to create
stories outside the box it's all about
showing Lightning McQueen story of him
getting stranded in a small town where
he gets to learn the true meaning of
friendship and family the movie itself
is by far one of the most popular Pixar
movies ever and for all the right
reasons
who doesn't love talking racecars with a
ton of personnel
cars to the second cars movie came a few
years after the first one and the bus
for it was honestly amazing Pixar I
wanted to test whether the popularity of
the first movie could be duplicated and
they did a pretty good job with it
Cars 2 has it all an emotional story and
brilliant one-liners of course the first
movie still reigns superior but the
second is pretty close and if you're
looking for a tearjerker don't worry
it's there and it's glorious one thing
cars 2 has that the first one doesn't is
brand new characters that really bring
out the spark and tons of comedy plus
there's a bonus of added car romance
because you know why not you're pretty
yes all right thank you cars 3 the
popularity of the second Cars movie
remains strong enough to produce the
third one and really turn the movies
into a franchise by the third one the
story sort of changed lightning McQueen
is now past his race car prime which is
kind of normal since he'd be way too old
cars 3 focuses more on mentorship and
learning how to stay humble and control
your ego it still brings an important
life lesson which is to not be selfish
and use your skills to bring up someone
else it also shows how easy it is to
lose confidence and how hard it is to
gain it all back unless you have people
around you to believe in you we're
already crying and the movie hasn't even
started yet inside out inside out came
in 2015 but we bet you've totally
forgotten about this gem the storyline
of the movie is pretty straightforward
it talks about Riley a teen who doesn't
know how to deal with her emotions after
her family moved to a new city each
emotion is an actual character which
makes the movie pretty original it's all
about Riley's mind and how she feels
with the complicated stage of her life
inside outs might be a movie you totally
forgot about and it might not even be on
your top tuned Pixar movies list
but we bet you'll change your mind about
it after Yuri watch this movie as an
adult it's absolutely heartwarming take
her to the moon or be Coco released in
2017 Coco is relatively new to the Pixar
world but it still made a huge splash
the minute it came out its focus is the
celebration of Mexican culture and a
chance for Pixar to focus on different
ethnicities for the first time this Dory
revolves around a 12 year old me
who has a single passion in life he
wants to be a musician this passion of
course doesn't go down well with the
rest of his family along with a touching
story the movie features plenty of
cultural moments that will really make
you stop your heart out in the best way
possible bugs life a bug's life is an
old-school fix our movie made back in
1998 it's actually only the second movie
the company ever made featuring an
amazing cast a bug's life takes on
exactly what the title suggests the life
of bugs it's pretty amazing how creative
Pixar got with this movie because truth
be told the storyline is absolutely
fantastic and the characters have an
amazing personality we won't spoil it
for you because you have to see it for
yourself but trust us this will make you
see ant in a completely different way
The Incredibles 1 are the Incredibles
this movie is a complete masterpiece and
one you just have to see with your
family The Incredibles is a longtime
fave for many this very surprising
superhero movie has it all funny
characters and action-packed storylines
and it plays with your emotions just
enough to make you both laugh and cry in
the span of one hour it also brings a
fabulous insight in the superhero
fashion and provides some touching
backstories that are hard to erase from
your mind seriously
capes have a whole new meaning after you
watch The Incredibles knotek's
The Incredibles - due to the success of
the first movie The Incredibles - were a
pleasant surprise for many and it's
actually one of those sequels that
managed to be just as entertaining as
the first movies The Incredibles - also
focuses on the youngest of the family
and we all know how many theories were
made about Jack Jack a bunch of other
stuff happens but the truth is
everything is just as heartwarming as
the first one The Incredibles franchise
is the best to watch on the family movie
night just make sure you get those
tissues ready because your tears will
definitely need them ratatouille
ok this movie is a total classic it's
pretty much up there with The
Incredibles cars and several other Pixar
movies we'll talk about in a moment it's
also one of those movies that shows
Pixar has no limits when it comes to
storylines and characters a movie about
a chef rat you don't see that every day
ratatouille introduces Remy the rats who
is actually in a maze
in chef but of course he doesn't get a
chance because he's different a bunch of
other stuff happens but you just have to
see it for yourself
got it to a might not be the most
quotable Pixar movie ever but it's
definitely the one that sticks with you
for life wall-e let's be honest when was
the last time you saw Bali do you
remember the storyline if the answer is
no it's time to re-watch this classic
wall-e is all about a binocular eyes
robot quite similar to ET the lesson of
this movie is perhaps a bit more surreal
than any others it shows the reality of
the humanity from an outside perspective
since it does have a lot of silence in
the movie it means that the characters
don't have any lines while this might
definitely put some people off you have
to give it a chance because trust us it
will grab your heart and you will melt
[Music]
Toy Story 1 now let's talk about the
very first movie created by Pixar Toy
Story is where it's all started the
revolution began it's one of those
completely unexpected movies that really
took off and show just how much kids get
attached to toys but it also took that
to the next level and explored the
secret life of those toys Toy Story has
a surprising amount of action along with
plenty of moments that will make you cry
your eyes out it's where it all begins
but definitely not to where it all ends
Toy Story View sequels are never as
successful as the originals but that's
not the case for Pixar and Toy Story it
turns out that the second toy story was
just as well-received and perhaps even
more than expected the plot is all about
woody getting kidnapped because he looks
like a valuable collectible just like
the first movie it features plenty of
touching moments and arguably has an
even better and slightly more emotional
soundtrack although many people still
only refer to the first movie when they
talk about Toy Story the sequel
definitely shouldn't be forgotten
Toy Story 3 can you believe that toy
story's third movie turned out to be one
that broke the most sales records it's
all about Andy becoming a teenager which
means that he's leaving behind most of
his childhood toys it happens in every
kid's life the toys get left abandoned
but how does that make them feel it's an
emotional plotline that reminds us all
of the difficulties of growing up and
getting detached
our childhood memories the movie also
has an incredibly gruesome moment that
will make you close your eyes and reach
for that tissue box tears will
definitely fall the good dinosaur say
what never heard of this movie we don't
blame you
the good dinosaur is a typical kid movie
that doesn't really interest the adult
world as much as some of the others but
the good dinosaur is indeed a Pixar
movie it represents a world in which the
dinosaurs and humans live side by side
and an adorable little dinosaur makes an
unlikely friendship
this movie is adorably sweet although
definitely not as complex as some of the
others on our list have you ever seen it
let us know what you thought about the
good dinosaur or any other Pixar movies
in the comments below if you liked
videos like this one make sure you hit
that subscribe button don't forget to
check out our community section where
you can talk about your favorite movies
TV shows and much more thank you for
tuning in to the things or stick around
for more fun
[Music]